New York Times national security
correspondent David Sanger covered the
nuclear summit with North Korea hero
quote if mr. Trump allows this
negotiation to become about limiting the
North's capabilities rather than
eliminating them he will repeat the
moves that he castigated mr. Obama for
making in Iran if he insists on getting
it all complete verifiable irreversible
denuclearization he risks coming up
empty-handed
Sanger is also a best-selling author his
new book is the perfect weapon war
sabotage and fear in the cyber age it
goes inside the rise of cyber warfare
and how cyber attacks are reshaping
global power David Sanger good morning
great to be back great to have you here
we're gonna get to this book because
it's I think just as scary as a nuclear
threat in some ways but first because
you've covered North Korea for decades
this idea will trump eventually get to
that complete and verifiable stage I'd
be surprised if he does look I applaud
the effort to go meet Kim jong-un we've
tried one method here for 35 years of
dealing with the North Koreans it's
failed every five so why not try having
the leaders meet and try this from the
top down I think what Kim jong-un is
trying to get to is an arms control
agreement something in which he will
maintain a minimum force that he knows
will keep the world from overthrowing
his regime and that's what the United
States has said it would never sell us
almost like Pakistan almost exactly like
Pakistan the president said there's no
longer a nuclear threat he when he came
home and tweeted that do you think
that's true I think it was somewhat
remarkable he it was a good meeting it's
good to have changed the tone nothing
has really changed on the ground yet in
in North Korea they still the same
number of weapons they had beforehand it
was would be a little bit like President
Kennedy after meeting Khrushchev for the
first time saying the Soviet threat was
over or Reagan after meeting with
Gorbachev well and it's also been a
longtime criticism for anybody who
declares peace in our time too quickly
for the last 60 70 years of history tell
me this David we had Condoleezza Rice on
this show and she said the tests for
inspections are snap inspections we
heard
a lot about that with respect to the
Iran deal so inspecting the nuclear
program of North Korea how do you think
that will go forward and is that the
next big question she's right it's snap
inspections but it's also inspections
everywhere any time in a country that is
full of tunnels full of hidden locations
and this is going to be the hard part
and it may explain why secretary Pompeo
was so snappish with a reporter on his
plane the other day when they started
asking about verification David the
North Koreans have already successfully
carried out an attack against the United
States under Kim jong-un a cyber attack
and that's what you write about that's
right you know what's happened with
cyber Noora is that in the years since
the u.s. did the big attack on Iran's
nuclear plant what was called Stuxnet or
Operation Olympic Games was was the name
for it we have seen an explosion of
cyber used by different states as a
short of war way of attacking other
nations and the North Koreans are a
great example of it because if you do
this subtly enough you can avoid
retaliation so they took out 70% of Sony
Pictures computer systems all right
imagine but they got basically sanctions
in return
and the reason you avoid retaliation is
a it's hard to figure out exactly who's
at fault but also isn't it be that the
u.s. is incredibly vulnerable and if you
get in a back and a forth we who depend
on our cyber world could be in bad shape
that's absolutely right and the more I
got into the reporting for the book
which really comes out of reporting I've
done for The Times over the years I was
struck by the fact that American
presidents are very concerned about
striking back because of our continued
vulnerabilities and the biggest example
here was President Obama in trying to
figure out how to deal with Vladimir
Putin in the middle of the 2016 election
you know every time somebody would come
to him the proposal and it's full of
them here cut off the Russians from the
from the world financial system go after
Putin's own money it's a well what if he
comes back on election day in the
election machines which they knew he was
already probing but David part of the
problem I love the title of the book the
perfect weapon and it is that because
there's no visual evidence that a great
crime has been committed
but you said we've got to rethink
secrecy America prides itself on secrecy
and not sharing what we know and how we
do it you said we have to do we have to
do that a different way now in some ways
Gail the classification surrounding
cyber is one of the biggest reasons that
we've got a continued threat it's one of
the first weapons was ever developed by
the intelligence community and they're
naturally secretive and I understand
that and they don't want to reveal the
ways that we both defend ourselves I do
offense but it gets into a big problem
and the big problem is that if you don't
begin to talk about your capabilities if
you don't talk about what you may do in
return you've created no deterrence at
all and you never consent rules about
what's off-limits if we wanted to say
election systems are off limits
we'd have to then commit that we're not
going to attack someone else's election
systems and believe it or not there are
people in the US government who would
raise objections to that Wow yeah you
call it a digital Pearl Harbor Pearl
Harbor in the making it's very very
scary stuff but important yeah great
reporting yeah thank you very much great
to be there they take us behind the
scenes thank you David Sanger the
perfect weapon will go on sale Tuesday
wherever you like to buy your books